esta vez vamos a seguir girando
funciones alrededor del eje de las x muy
pronto veremos funciones que quieren
alrededor del eje leyes sin embargo
vamos a tomarnos un ejemplo que sea un
poco más difícil que el anterior puede
suponer otra vez que estos son los ejes
esto es un eje de leyes y esté aquí va a
ser un eje de las x bien en el primer
vídeo estuvimos analizando la función
que igual a raíz de x entonces para
seguir en la misma sintonía voy a seguir
con esa función
voy a dibujar aquí la función que igual
a raíz de x y lo que nosotros hacíamos
era girar esa función alrededor del eje
de las equis y para esto tomábamos dos
puntos de referencia tomaba yo el 0 y el
1 no es así
bien ahora me voy a preguntar en esta
ocasión qué pasa si yo compaginó dos
funciones en el mismo plano canciano
cómo va a quedar el sólido de revolución
de estas dos funciones supongamos que
ahora tomo la función y igual a x
cuadrada se dan cuenta x cuadrada y raíz
de x se juntan en dos puntos en el punto
cero
1a y se intersectan y esto es muy claro
porque raíz de cero es cero y cero al
cuadrado es cero y raíz de uno es uno y
uno cuadrados uno bueno y ahora sí ya
que tengo mis dos funciones yo lo que
voy a querer hacer es girar el área que
está en medio de las dos funciones voy a
querer girar el área que está en medio
de las dos funciones alrededor del eje
de las x y que salida de revolución me
va a quedar con los sacó el volumen de
ese sólido de revolución bueno llegamos
memoria si nosotros giramos la función y
igual a raíz de x obteníamos con una
copa sólida completamente sólida voy a
intentar dibujarla aquí para que
recordemos un poco como nos quedaba nos
queda una copa completamente sólida
estaba totalmente llena pero en esta
ocasión le vamos a quitar un pedazo
adentro de la copa es como la tasa de
vaciado o como si tuviéramos la misma
copa solamente que adentro está vacío
con una copa con un hueco adentro esto
es lo que nos va a quedar de girar esta
función alrededor del eje de las x tal
vez sea un poco difícil que ustedes
visualicen qué es lo que está pasando y
más si yo no soy un gran dibujante la
computadora pero bueno
explicarles esto de una manera diferente
para ver si así entienden qué es lo que
está pasando
supongamos que me tomo la función
original la función con la que empezamos
era igual a la raíz de x lo voy a
escribir esta función al girar la
alrededor del eje de las x nos quedaba
el soy una revolución que era la copa
original bien ahora supongamos que a ese
sólido de revolución yo le quito le el
volumen que me da al girar esta área que
estoy dibujando de rojo alrededor del
eje das x de hecho esta área que estoy
dibujando de rojo es el sólido de
revolución que me queda al yo girar la
función que iguala x cuadrada si yo giro
la función llegó a la equis cuadrada
alrededor del eje de las x obtendría un
sólido de revolución muy parecido a este
que estoy dibujando donde ésta sería su
boca y todo lo demás sería el cuerpo del
fluido de revolución y lo que voy a
hacer es girar mi copa original y
quitarle el volumen que me sale al
dirigir a la función de igual a equis
cuadrada de hecho ahora que recuerdo no
sé si alguna vez ustedes han estado en
marruecos pero en marruecos hay un
utensilio de cocina que se llama timing
cuál tiene una etapa muy parecida al
sodio de revolución que me queda al
girar la función james wallace cuadrada
alrededor del eje de las equis pero
bueno entonces ahora si está bien
planteado en el problema yo lo que voy a
querer es sacar el volumen del sólido de
revolución que me queda de la función
igual a raíz de x ya este restarle el
volumen que me queda de la función que
iguala x cuadrada al hacer la gira
alrededor del eje de las datos van a
girar alrededor del cliente del eje es
las 10 así que viene tomemos el color un
color especial para hacer este cálculo
de volumen
voy a anotarlo aquí el volumen es igual
y bueno primero va a ser el volumen de
la función igual a raíz de x entonces es
la integral de 0 a 1 quedan nuestros
puntos de intersección de hecho puede
ser un problema para ustedes que en un
examen les digan a ver encuentre los
puntos de intersección de dos funciones
y esto salía al igualar al igualar las
dos funciones la una a la otra bien pero
en este caso pues ya nos habíamos dado
cuenta que las intersecciones serán 0 y
1 entonces voy a poner la integral de 0
a 1 del primer volumen pero el primer
volumen de es igual a la raíz de x
entonces si ustedes se acuerdan la
fórmula del volumen era pi por el radio
al cuadrado por de x y acuérdense que
estos al día de tener un rectángulo y
girando alrededor del eje de las x donde
decíamos que el radio del disco que
obtendría al girar ese rectángulo
alrededor de medidas x era fx y que la
anchura de ese disco era de x siempre
así
para acordarme de la fórmula entonces
tengo raíz de equis y esto lo voy a
llevar pues al cuadrado porque era pi
por radio al cuadrado este es el área de
un círculo entonces voy a poner pie
afuera porque es la constante y
recuerden que las constantes salen de la
integral y que va a multiplicar la
integral de 01 de raíz de x elevado al
cuadrado de x bien pero la idea era que
a este volumen yo le iba a quitar el
volumen de la función y igual a x
cuadrado entonces pues vamos a
quitárselo de una vez para esto muchos
autores ponen en la misma integral la
resta de las dos funciones yo prefiero
que lo hagamos en dos integrales para
que no nos confundamos entonces le voy a
quitar menos porque otra vez es el área
de un círculo la integral de 01 de mi
función pero mi función ahora es x
cuadrados están de acuerdo
entonces me va a quedar pues fx es x
cuadrada que a su vez era mi radio
entonces me quedaba pues que tenía que
elevarlo al cuadrado va a ser x cuadrada
elevado al cuadrado d
y bien ya tengo mis dos e integrales
planteadas es cuestión de resolverlas
entonces el volumen que iba a ser el
primero y el factor común multiplica a
mis dos suman dos entonces lo voy a
sacar pi que multiplica a quien bueno
por una parte va a multiplicar a la
integral de cero a uno de raíz de x al
cuadrado de x que cuánto es esto pues
estos x están de acuerdo reid de x
elevado al cuadrado pues es x entonces
voy a poner solamente x y ahora también
tengo que la integral de 01 de x
cuadrada al cuadrado donde a ver voy a
contar las dos integrales esta vez x
cuadrada al cuadrado es x cuánta
entonces le tengo que quitar x cuarta y
todo esto x de x muy bien y ojo con
telas 12 integrales porque la integral
es aditiva y además tienen los mismos
límites de integración bien pues ahora
voy a resolver las integrales esto va a
servicio multiplica pues la primitiva de
x que es pues x cuadrada entre 2 las
integrales hay veces que son sencillas
bien
y ahora saquemos integral de x4 hay que
sumarle 1 al exponente y dividirlo entre
ese mismo entonces me queda x quinta
entre 5 bien y todo esto hay que
evaluarlo en los límites de integración
es decir de 1 a 0 y esto por el teorema
fundamental de cálculo así que vamos a
evaluar de una vez que voy a obtener
cambiamos de color y de esto va a ser
igual a pi pi se mantiene como factor
común y bueno me va a quedar en 1 me
queda un medio menos un quinto
entonces tengo un medio ya esto le quitó
un quinto y ya se dieron cuenta en cero
pues no me queda nada cero al cuadrado
entre 1200 por pipo es cero entonces no
hay que evaluarlo en cero bien ahora
habrá que hacer la resta de quebrados y
voy a sacar el mínimo común múltiplo que
es 10 10 entre 2 por 15 y menos 10 en 35
por un es 2 ya está resto ya la tengo
cinco menos dos estrés entonces pues le
queda al final que el volumen es tres pi
entre diez el volumen que yo estaba
buscando de mitad se de vacío se redujo
a 3 pi entre 10 un problema de quebrados
pero bueno de cualquier manera en el
siguiente vídeo voy a girar funciones
alrededor del ejes las pies así que no
se pierdan el siguiente vídeo